sbagliarmi
a volte fatico io stesso a rivedermi
quando faccio ste cose ma lasciamo
perdere l tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono vaghi j
oggi siamo il nuovo blog che ogni ma che
faccio ma dalla mia struccato un braccio
da un po che si spezzava tutti ragazzi
prima di cominciare partiamo preparate
la settimana per questa settimana è
stata vinta da alessandra capatosta
disegno è bellissimo soltanto che tipo
sembra esageratamente effemminato non lo
so perché mi sembra lui
un cap a parte questo è splendido mini
grazie mille passandone news ragazzi
volevo ringraziarvi di cuore perché tipo
ci sono stati gli mtv digital days la
settimana scorsa che è stato un delirio
ragazzi eravate non ho mai visto mai
visto così tanta gente ragazzi è stato
grazie cioè io non so veramente no spero
di essere stato chiaro
grazie comunque veramente grazie di
cuore che altro news ragazzi
importantissima perché scolari che ha
nello scorso blog che ho fatto vedere il
bracciale questo ma che mi hanno fatto
fare che veramente me l'ha fatto un sito
ma non è ke bello lo sfondo offuscato e
siccome ragazzi non l'avete variamente
chiesto tutti non di non avrei dovuto
mai farlo vedere
mi sono i dati 300 mila messaggi sulla
pagina di ovunque mi hanno chiesto come
ho fatto a prenderlo è stato un d'elia
da ragazzo ho chiesto al sito se potevo
mettere pubblico la il braccialetto
grazie a viola hanno fatto in lega per
chi lo volesse prendere lascio al link
nella descrizione non chiedetemi basta
basta faccio sto notando che con lo
sfondo così posso fare quello che
vogliono mi si vede io tipo ho sputato
una roba così sotto sul muro l'asian
perda ragazzi dunque come ultima news
volevo dirvi che è la prossima settimana
ragazzi da 23 26 sarò usciranno vitolo
stessa quindi tranquilli incontrate
corre mondiale o cose così sarò a los
angeles perché mi hanno per niente
invitati all'anteprima di hicks man
nuovi indizi ma voglio farci un blog
uscirà una cosa epica a mio parere ci
farà un blog della madonna sarà il più
bello for spero quindi ragazzi quando
torno vedrete blog di los angeles perché
salati come in africa e non sono mai
andato pat è che non ho mai preso
l'aereo quindi
porca [ __ ]
tutti ragazzi farò un blog della madonna
per poi vedere tutto di tutto sarà epico
e detto queste ragazzine passare allo
scatto dei pacchi che sono belli questa
volta eccolo quale che ha tra l'altro
uno questo bellissimo tanto e ripartire
da questo ragazzi perché ogni volta che
mi inviato un pacco così mi chiedo al
postino che lo porta checa che cazzo di
domande si fa io non ho mai visto una
faccia più bella di questa sembra di
essere a natale anticipato ragazzi
dall'altro che io devo ancora capire da
che mi inviate quantità industriali ed i
giornali comunque grazie rosa perché
fate per assistere alla tecnologia rega
tenetevi pronti questo è il futuro una
conchiglia che ho scritto fa vj con cat
mario grazie mille sembra tipo di scatti
di aprire la busta delle figurine una
cosa così non ho effettivamente pensato
al fatto che poteva esserci un disegno
dentro quindi non ho giusto io l'ho
giusto io al ragazzi anche qui la faccia
di 8 reti è bellissima grazie di cuore
ha cassato c'è un dvd di madagascar la
madonna cos'è sto ragazzo un orologio
swag
[Musica]
ce li avevo leggermente storti rimangono
due ragazzi che sono enormi allora
l'ultimo voglio aprire per ultimo dei
ragazzi sono seriamente preoccupato di
vedere giuliana mi aspetto che per che
cazzo mi inviate i giornali non è
normale che cazzo
cos'è cos'è cos'è mezz'ora per trovare
questo fave fa vj di cacao delle fave j
fantastica è qualcuno c'ha una risposta
ragazzi ve lo faccio sapere che un carro
l'ultimo che estrarrà harry potter kit
ci metterai minimo due ore ad aprirlo
grazie grazie davvero cos'è sta roba
a noi lo scotch che ahi ahi scocciato lo
scotch sei un genio si è aperto davvero
bellissimo questo grazie è bello molto
carino figo
l'ometto via c'è una cosa che ti può
cazzo io non so chi è più figura mente
tra me e la mia granik investimento c'è
c'è gara di gnocca gene e c'è anche una
bacchetta che mi sembra più un dildo di
legno per che tirò fuori delle cose che
non ci starebbero umanamente in un pack
corse è la madonna che cazzo ne inviato
hagrid credo che sia un mantello però
non ne sono si coprono ammetterlo ma
vada vada [ __ ] a c'è scritto made in
china su sto coso non è normale ma va
lasciar lasciam perdere il made in china
vera la gente ha bisogno di noi ragazzi
devo andare
ho trovato anche infamous 2 nel pacco
cosa c'entra come reporter però certo
senso questo ragazzino lei anche
stavolta ci sono state c'è stato uno
scarto fantastico e direi che possiamo
passare al fuori risponda la prima
domanda dice famigli sponde favi matte
fai parte degli illuminati
ovviamente no adesso mi devi spiegare
che cazzo c'entro io con il cazzo
la seconda domanda rivela skeleton games
fa vi risponde
cos'è sto cosa cosa cazzo appena
guardato e zecchin e 93 fuori
risponderle ore st possa chiamare così
stai tranquilla ed chi era la tua
capigliatura folta ti hanno mai preso in
giro spulciate per farglielo leggere in
merito nessuno mi ha mai preso in giro
per il fatto che io c'ho dei capelli che
non sono molto normali però c'è io sono
fatto così cioè nel senso non è non mi
faccio problemi coi capelli che nessuno
mi ha mai rotto le palle per i miei
capelli
stai tranquillo al nayan fuori risponde
con fatti con una foto di quando ha
iniziato a fare video è chi è che cos'è
quel coso cos'è cos'hai in testa amico
mio di via denti e fare risponde ma tu
registra in mutande io non registra in
mutande se permetti io io registro nudo
o che non era una presa per il culo
perché poi qualcuno ci crede davvero e
dal mondo fa risponde fai canestro senza
guardare
[Musica]
quindi ragazzi le domande di oggi
finiscono qui tra l'altro a tono
accaldato leggermente questo mantello
che di finire con la fabio domanda terme
le fai domande sono conosciutissime per
essere intelligenti spontanee culturali
quindi perché quando facciamo la cacca
facciamo anche la pipì disponetevi con
un commento qui sotto ragazzi e niente
come al solito servito ed è piaciuto
io voglio dare le risposte per mille è
piaciuto come al solito lasciato un
commento mi piace è incapace di facebook
e come non i video tratta la descrizione
sono se dovresti discrete vinci mettiamo
un prossimo vinto da ragazzi
[Musica]